what about rights that that is one term
that everyone loves in america the right
the left the wokies the libertarians
there's a broad consensus that in
america we have rights
one of the founders mockingly put it
what are we going to put in our bill of
rights the right to get up when you want
go to sleep when you want you can't list
all the rights that's all the possible
things that human beings could do what
you don't have though you don't have a
right to welfare you don't have a right
to health care you don't have a right to
self-esteem by making other people
praise you for whatever you're doing
this is not the sanitized version of you
know the founders with powdered wigs
talking about abstract principles this
is tom west exposing the whole of the
foundation including the parts of it
that make us uncomfortable
we've lost the frame for thinking
clearly about politics in the modern
world i can do anything i can become a
cat i mean this is one of my favorites
these people today like if you had told
george washington that's what you're
building and that's what you're standing
for he would have just looked at you
like i don't know what kind of a rock
you crawled out from under the founders
thought their own enterprise is worthy
is noble they thought what they were
doing was something grand to establish
and create a society that protects the
common good we are going to discuss
what the founders thought about natural
rights immigration foreign policy sex
marriage
going beyond the mere presentation of
the abstract principles so contrast it
with the way of life of a contemporary
america to accentuate the differences so
as to bring it all to life the
republican government that's the best
way to organize politics if you can do
it that's only possible if you have a
healthy american people
and what do you do when you don't have a
healthy american people
what do you do when you have an american
people that can't figure out minimal
duties of citizenship
[Music]